the supreme court plans to issue more
rulings this morning as we wait for a
final decision on the justices possibly
overturning roe v wade in the latest cbs
news poll 50 percent of americans say
they would in their words care a lot if
the ruling that makes abortion legal
nationwide it's thrown out if that
happens it would run against decisions
by other countries to make abortion more
available
holly williams recently visited one of
them ireland and met a woman who talked
about her own difficult experience
the doctor doing the scan got very quiet
and she turned the screen away and she
said
is your husband here
amy callahan is originally from north
carolina but has lived in dublin with
her irish husband for 17 years
when she got pregnant with their second
child in 2017 she was ecstatic until her
12-week scan the top of the baby skull
hadn't formed properly so the whole
brain was
outside of the skull
and
she said
it's not a pregnancy
the baby's not going to live
at most she was told the baby would
survive a few days after birth
she felt an abortion was the kindest
choice i just couldn't imagine how
how how it would
how it would work that you would give
birth
only for only to watch the baby die and
probably struggle to breathe and
probably be in pain
but in ireland abortion was illegal in
almost all cases forcing amy to travel
to england for the procedure
she told us she was lucky she could
afford to do so instead of carrying a
baby for months that she'd never take
home
it's i think it's inhumane to me like as
a mother it would have been but also to
the baby
um it just seems like an incredibly
horrific
way to pass away
ireland is nearly 80 percent catholic
and used to have some of the most
restrictive abortion laws in the world
so strict that in 2012 when savita
halipanova began to miscarry her baby at
17 weeks pregnant she was denied an
abortion
as a result she developed sepsis which
killed her
her death fueled angry protests
eventually leading to a referendum on
abortion
with more than two-thirds of voters in
support
abortion was finally legalized in
ireland in 2018.
in fact abortion is now widely available
in nearly all of europe though with some
conditions if roe v wade is overturned
and some u.s states ban abortion even in
cases of rape they'll be joining a club
that includes iraq egypt and nicaragua
there are still many in ireland who
oppose abortion rights
while for others the new laws don't go
far enough
abortion is now legal in all
circumstances in ireland until the 12th
week of pregnancy and in very limited
circumstances until the 24th week
in 40 years dr peter boylan says women
should be free to make the best decision
for themselves without the law
interfering at all he's an ob gyn who's
delivered more than 4 000 babies
what is your advice to americans about
what the reality is of living in a place
where a woman can't get an abortion
living in a country the size of the
united states and the size of the
individual states where a woman cannot
access abortion care will end up with
maternal death
there is no question about that women
will die as a consequence of this
[Music]
he says if roe v wade is overturned it's
the poorest women in america who can't
afford to travel outside their state
who'll suffer the most while women who
get abortions could face prosecution
it's medieval
you know
what is supposed to be the greatest
democracy in the world it's just it's a
tragedy for the united states amy
callahan says nobody should judge women
who choose to have an abortion i think
it's a very sad move
there are so many different reasons why
somebody might want to end a pregnancy i
think it's going to have a detrimental
effect on on women and children
for cbs mornings holly williams ireland